like we did with parabolic mirrors what
I really want to do in this video is
just put objects at different distances
relative to this convex lens and just
think about what its image will look
like and the whole point of doing that
is one look just going through all of
the different situations but more just
getting practice of how to think about
it so let's first put an object out here
that's more than two focal lengths away
from the lens so I'll put the object
I'll put the object right here and we'll
just do our classic arrow and actually
I'll make a point here when we did when
we dealt with parabolic mirrors we
talked about the distance of two focal
lengths being our center of curvature
over here we're just going to call it
two focal lengths because it's really
not the center of curvature of the or
the or or this distance really isn't the
radius of curvature of each of these
curves we're just going to call it two
focal lengths so with that said let's
just actually try to figure out what the
image of this thing will look like as
the light from it gets refracted through
this lens so like always it's useful to
draw one ray remember every point on
this object is emitting Ray's in every
direction because it's diffusely
reflecting light so what we do is we
just pick rays that are convenient so we
could go from the tip of this arrow and
go parallel go parallel to our principal
axis just like that and I'm not going to
show all of the internal refraction
within this lens right here but we know
that if we if we enter the lens parallel
to the principal axis when we get
refracted we will go through the focal
point on the other side of the lens so
we will go through the focal point on
the other side of the lens and we'll do
the same and now on the on the left side
of the lens will do another ray that
goes through the focal point on the left
side and then comes out parallel so
let's do that I'll do that in another
color so it comes out let me so it comes
the incident the incident ray goes
through the left focal point and when it
gets refracted it will now be parallel
it will it will now be parallel and so
the light that came from
point in the object will reconverge I
guess we could say will converge right
over here and so if you did this for
every point on this object if you did a
point in the middle right over here
would reconverge right over here if you
did this point right over here it would
reconverge right over there and so the
image of this object is going to look
like this is going to look like this so
it's going to be a real image the Rays
actually converge here so it is a real
it is a real inverted image it was
pointing up before now it's pointing
down and in this situation it's actually
going to be smaller than the original
it's a real smaller inverted image let's
do a couple of other scenarios let me
let me I copy and pasted this before
starting this video to save on time
so let's do a situation now where the
object is at this at the two focal
distances I guess we could call it so
let's let's put the object right over
here let's pull it out do it in blue
this time but we do the exact same thing
you might want to do it on paper for
your on your own just to get some
practice doing it but we'll do one ray
that is parallel one ray that is
parallel and when it's parallel when it
gets refracted it will go through the
focal point on the other side and then
we'll do another ray that goes through
the focal point on the left side and
then it will become parallel and then it
will become parallel and they could re
converge or they converge right over
there
and so you can see that this is actually
a this is this is actually a
parallelogram this distance this
distance right there is going to be the
same thing as that distance over here
there's actually I don't want to say
symmetry you can't flip it over but
these this is a and this distance right
over here is going to be the same thing
as this distance over here I won't go
into all of the geometry but where and
if you do this with really straight
lines it would just come out that way
but this will just be an inverted image
that's exactly the same size at the
exact same distance actually I didn't
talk about distance in this one over
here over here it's a real image it's
smaller and it's also going to be closer
in than this one was it's going to be
closer to the lens this is going to be
really the same image or the same SOT
the image is going to be the same size
as the original object but it's going to
be inverted but it's going to be at the
same distance from the lens just on the
other side and once again this is a real
image let's do another one let me let me
copy and paste so let's stick something
between one focal length and two focal
lengths so let's put something right
over let's put my object let's put my
object right over there so once again
let's go parallel we go parallel then we
will refract through the focus on the
other side I can do a better job than
that we can go through the focus on the
other side and then let's go through the
focus on the left side and then we will
refract and go parallel and we will
refract and go parallel so here we will
have we will have remember I could do
this with every point I'm just doing it
with the tip because I know the base
will that will converge over there if I
just took two points it would it would
converge right back there and then if I
did that with a point right over here if
I did that same exercise it would go
right over there and so the whole image
the whole image would show up over here
so here it's real it's inverted it is
now larger and it is and it is now
further away from the lens than the
object just on the other side so this is
really kind of the reverse of the first
example the first example the object was
large and more than two focal lengths
away and the image was in this range now
the object is here and now the image is
on the other side so they're kind of
there there it's really just the other
side of that first example so let's do
let's do a couple more let's do a couple
more so let's put the object at the
focal point let's put the object at the
focal point see what happens and
sometimes people memorize this type of
things for physics exams for optics
again today you don't need to all you
have to do is remember just just think
about two rays usually from the tip of
the arrow that because that gives you a
sense of what the image will look like
and you
one parallel and one that goes through
the focal point and well with that said
we're going to do something slightly
different when something is sitting at
the focal point when something is
sitting at the focal point one is we
could do the parallel ray so the
parallel ray it will be refracted
through the focal point on the other
side and then instead of and instead of
going something that doing a ray that
goes through the focal point on this
side because it's actually you can't
you're sitting on the focal point right
there let's do a ray that does not get
refracted and we did a similar thing
with the parabolic mirrors what I want
to do is array or actually the parabolic
Muellers we did a ray that went right at
the center but over here will go right
to the center of the lens where it won't
get refracted so it's just going to go
straight through it's just going to go
straight through the center of the lens
and so what you have here is both of
these rays that were that we're
diverging from this point from this tip
they don't reconverge anywhere and they
don't even look like they're diverging
from another point if someone's eyeball
if someone's eyeball is right over here
they're just going to see these as two
parallel rays of light so no image will
form not a real image or a virtual image
so we can say we can say no no image is
going to form now the last case is let
me draw this I'm running out of space
let me just paste it over here so the
last case let's put the object less than
one focal distance away so let's put the
object let's stick let's put the object
right over here and think about what
happens so once again if a light ray
from this tip we're to go parallel it
will be refracted through the focal
point on the other side and then let's
do another light ray go in a direction
as if it were coming from the direction
of the focal point on this side so if it
were to come from that direction the
light ray would go like that and then it
would come out on the other side
parallel so it would come out on the
other side parallel so clearly these two
light rays are not converging so no real
image is going to form but they do look
like they're diverging from some point
they do look like they're diverging from
let me
continue these lines they do they both
look like they're coming from a point
they look like they're coming from a
point right over there so what's going
to happen well if someone's eyes are
processing these light rays they're
going to see the tip of this arrow all
the way up here they're going to see the
base of this arrow they're going to see
the base of this arrow down here and
essentially what's going to happen
essentially what's going to happen is
they're going to see a magnified they
are going to see a magnified version
they are going to see a magnified
virtual image I should say then we're
going to see a magnified virtual image
of the actual arrow anyway hopefully you
found that hopefully you found that
interesting